les candidats ont publié leur très
attendu déclaration de patrimoine et
c'est valérie pécresse qui est en tête
dans ce classement avec près de 10
millions d'euros de patrimoine de fabien
roussel était à découvert de 219 euros
quand il a transmis des informations à
la haute autorité pour la transparence
de la vie publique eric zemmour n'est
pas stéphane plaza même s'il possède
cinq appartements dans paris lapierre ça
rassure patrimoine estimé à un peu plus
de 4 millions d'euros le président
sortant emmanuel macron se place à la 8e
place avec un peu plus d'un demi million
d'euros le dernier du classement et le
candidat du nouveau parti
anticapitaliste philippe poutou il
détient 122 mille euros ils sont tous
des espérances je veux dire on a géré la
pierre on a un petit livret par ci par
là il ya quelques livres est gênant
c'est désespérant 6-6-6 médias de là il
me semble il n'y a
aucune audace
aucun bitkom
exemple je précise que c'est une
déclaration sur l'honneur et que ces
chiffres ne sont contrôlés par aucune
organisation faut bien se rappeler que
l'argent l'argent c'est le meilleur des
serviteurs le pire des maîtres
conduite commerciale
on dit quelque chose qui est nécessaire
en complément de ce qu'on appelle une
redevance voilà mais c'est bien si la
flambée des prix du carburant est très
inquiétante certains préfèrent s'en
amuser
si vous êtes en manque d'idées pour un
cadeau cet internaute lance un appel
explicite d'autres préfèrent songer à la
voiture de demain
mieux vaut en rire qu'en pleurer et pour
les plus malins qui ne veulent pas payer
il existe peut-être une technique
[Applaudissements]
si bien que ce n'est pas exagéré que de
dire que cette crise énergétique ce choc
énergétique de 2022 est comparable en
intensité en brutalité au choc pétrolier
de 1973 jean lassalle salue son public
même s'il n'a encore rien gagné
le candidat se lance dans un tour de
france
dans un bus à son effigie avant je me
sens bien et ça devrait être bien se
passer il ya un lien particulier
à 3 à 3 bref quand
[Musique]
à bien on s'amuse en s'amusant vous avez
raison un moyen d'aller au contact de
gagner des voix de partager son
programme et son franc-parler
jeudi à l'ats d'acteur écoute moi je
veux où je bouge toi le cul toro che un
commis 10 au 12 et lenski et sa troupe
reprennent les codes qui ont fait leur
succès humour irrévérencieux blague un
peu vulgos et corée en talons aiguille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
merci
ouais
si jean luc mélenchon est élu président
dans deux mois est ce qu'ils continuent
les livraisons d'armes à l'ukraine non
nous on a dit depuis vous arrêtez
entièrement mail rien armand il y en a
très peu parlé des armes françaises
franchement cd gilet pare-balles et
quelques missiles antichars mais pour
qu'elle avait la liste des parts dont
vous avez la liste des armes fournies
par la france bien je vais vous dire je
siège à la commission défense air mais
je ne vois pas vous dire eh ben vous
c'est pour ça que je pose la question
parce qu'on ne la connais pas venez nous
la donner la bande n'hésite pas à
descendre en dessous de la ceinture voir
a laissé tomber la ceinture
[Musique]
on
e
pour
[Musique]
j'avais cru comprendre qu'ils avaient un
secret défense sur cette question mais
je me suis peut-être trompé écoutez quoi
qu'il en soit la france a livré des
missiles ce que je veux vous dire c'est
que le matériau venez de le dire les
auditeurs les spectateurs leur douleur à
l'endroit du des choses maintenant mais
qu'en pense et je ne sais pas le détail
mais ça ressemble à signifie simplement
en commission ça ressemble manifestement
à cela on referme ses actualités avec
cet interprète en langue des signes
australien qui va vous faire relativiser
si vous pensez avoir passé une sale
journée
par un pigeon d'un canadair
c'est donc sur scène qu'il fait campagne
et on est loin très loin les discours
ultra formaté
il
finalement détenir d'autres robots aux
mines ya
elle est au coeur d'une vraie polémique
après avoir voulu vendre l'eau de son
bain à ses abonnés aujourd'hui elle va
plus loin en vendant ses culottes salle
faut pas rester là
voulez vous allez pas rester feu ouais
ne voulait pas parler pourquoi paris
j'ai retrouvé l'âme de vivaldi les
quatre saisons le minimalisme j'adore
effectivement il n'y avait pas trop de
choses éliane qui sort le truc vival du
machin moi j'ai rien compris jallet
parce qu'elle d'user de chiner ou en
fait dans un dictionnaire les enfants
qui vont s'exposer aux écrans juste
avant d'aller à l'école vont avoir un
risque multiplié par 6 de troubles du
langage qui est inquiétant dans cette
étude c'est que 85 % des enfants de
moins de deux ans sont exposés aux
écrans mais attention il n'a suffi que
de 20 minutes pour avoir un impact sur
leur santé ce qui veut donc dire que ce
n'est pas tant la durée qui compte mais
aussi le moment où vous êtes exposés à
l'écran aujourd'hui tu as une nouvelle
idée tu vends tes culottes salle
non non non c'est pas d'école à 100
c'est claude que j'ai portée mais j'ai
su projet d'accord de ces prétendus
battu les apporter combien de fois
quelques heures quelques heures
seulement donc tu es tu verras tu
l'éventuelle avant combien ça s'emballe
la culotte le candidat écologiste
yannick jadot a fait appel à un célèbre
photographe américain spécialiste de la
scène hip hop outre atlantique pour la
photo de son affiche de campagne john
alton lemagnen c'est son nom a déjà
immortalisé djezzy nicki minaj dr dre ou
encore qu'un bris clamart à l'origine de
plus de 300 couvertures d'albums de rap
et de clips il a aussi travaillé avec
des artistes français dans le groupe ntm
la vérité mademoiselle
mais est ce que tu as déjà vendu des
culottes as tu as à ce que tu as du
journal régional 500 euros
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais tout est au menu assortiment de
charcuterie terrine de poisson et
salades du pin en regardant
j'ai vu beaucoup de choses vraiment me
plais la cupidon en mortadelle avec la
flèche en pâte et
celle là on me l'avait jamais fait 3 c
de la taxidermie mangeable